we're still waiting for the starget
announcement Still
Still when will it happen and how will
it happen welcome to serek your SciFi TV
and Movie
[Music]
Channel we have been hearing lots of
rumors recently and we do genuinely
believe we're building up to a Stargate
announcement and it literally could be
any day I actually check my feed
regularly I check my emails hourly
waiting for something waiting for one of
my sources to drop the bomb that it's
about to happen we've had a couple of
near misses and to be honest we're in a
little bit of a no man's land at the
moment again thanks to the strikes thank
you Disney and Netflix for walking out
on the SAG after talks last last week so
throwing everything up in the air once
again there was a genuine and honest
belief within the industry that the
actors would accept a deal roughly
similar to The Writers Guild and that
everyone would be back to work by the
start of November I was basically being
told that the plan was and might still
be to announce the Stargate movie by the
end of the month that's this month
that's October that we might actually
get an announcement by Halloween so why
do we think at the end of October well
Stargate Tim Keepers the computer game
comes out very very soon it's going to
be out sometime in the fall we don't
know exactly when but actually this week
there is going to be a big celebration
and announcement about the game hosted
by Slytherin the gate World guys are
going to be there to coincide with
actually the 29th anniversary of
Stargate the original movie coming out
that came out in
1994 another reason why it's very
possible we might get an announcement
got it could even be this week I've just
realized
that so yes I'm going to continue
checking my emails on an hourly basis so
we're hoping anytime now we've heard
lots and lots of rumors about
potentially sets being built we've heard
lots of rumors about directors we've
heard lots of rumors about people being
hired to develop a project
we've heard lots of rumors about MGM and
Amazon Executives banging heads over
what to actually do I've Heard lots of
rumors about people at MGM desperately
fighting to get Brad right back involved
in the series or movie we've been
hearing lots and lots but it has
actually kind of gone quiet right now
and I was always told just before we get
an announcement you will get a moment of
silence everybody will lock the doors no
information will get leaked they will
take it very seriously so when the
announcement does come out it is news
and it is exciting they do not want
people like me dropping the bombshell
first even though let's be honest I
probably will anyway so how will they
announce it well we know we had lots of
talk about San Diego ComicCon and then
very recently we had lots of talk about
New York ComicCon that they were going
to hopefully get actors up on stage and
announce Stargate I was able to tell you
that they were never going to announce
it at New York Comic Con that was an
event just for Amazon Amazon did book
out a 2hour thing on stage they talked
about a lot of Amazon stuff that's
coming back like the next series of boys
etc etc there was never any plan to have
any MGM project announced there I did
say look maybe there's a slim chance
they might do some sort of teaser thing
out of the blue you know surprise but
that was a very slim chance and no it
didn't happen I'm now being told that
look it's not not going to be a big
thing on stage they were hoping to do
that for San Diego Comic-Con but
obviously that chance came and went
thanks to the strikes it will just
simply be and very boringly be a press
release it will just be a statement
released from Amazon MGM saying this is
what we're going to be doing in the next
12 months Stargate probably won't even
get its own press release it's more
likely going to be a press release is
going to include things like Robocop and
several other projects that they've got
coming in in the next 12 months and US
Gators will just be looking for that
magic Stargate word we probably won't
get a lot of information straight away
about what they're actually doing other
than that it'll be a movie I am being
told that it looks like a director has
been signed on but that's
unconfirmed we believe there's a script
already in play etc etc
I know that Amazon would like to wait
until they can sign a couple of main
actors on in which case they're waiting
for the writer strike again thank you
Disney and Netflix for screwing that up
the actors in the studios though are
back in the negotiating room and the
studios are very very keen to have an
agreement in place and to have people
back to work by the start of November
so this little up
with the negotiation thank you Disney
and
Netflix might have slowed things down
and it might be that we don't get the
announcement this week like we were
hoping us Gators at this point are used
to disappointment we used to having
things delayed and we're used to having
things pushed back so hopefully this is
going to be the final hurdle however
Amazon may go ahead with the
announcement anyway I've been told by
people people again that work close to
this over at Amazon and MGM that
recently Amazon Executives did ask them
to review all of the pr and marketing
plans for several projects but they did
not include Stargate in that review now
there's two possibilities for that one
they've changed their minds they're not
going ahead with Stargate at all I think
that's unlikely or two it's because
actually they are going ahead they are
doing the announcement very very shortly
and they didn't want to review what they
were looking at because they already
knew what they were going to do to
announce it I think then we will get a
very big splashy announcement at San
Diego ComicCon in
2024 where they will be able to get all
of the actors past and present up on
stage they will make a big deal out of
the new Stargate project and hey by then
they might even have some early footage
to show us that is the point of doing
something on stage when you can then
actually make a big deal out of it you
can actually fill up at least an hour or
two hours you can interview people on
stage you can then actually show them
something you can do something that will
make the fans go freaking crazy at the
end of the day right now there isn't
anything to get on stage with and that
is why we will only get a very boring
text message basically from Amazon
saying yeah we're doing it and hopefully
I'll find out
first guys get into the comments and
tell me what you think is this very
boring is it going to be a massive let
down regardless how they do it to be
honest they could have had Richard Dean
Anderson doing back flips onto stage at
this point and I think we'd still been a
little bit disappointed because we've
been talking about it for so damn long
but at the end of of the day the result
is going to be the return of Stargate so
I think we'll be okay probably but what
do you think get to the comments as
always if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to
patreon.com sidre where most of our new
videos appear first and you get to see
them without the adverts and you even
get a free gift after three months for a
small contribution each month that
really supports the channel of course
can't say fairer than that right also go
to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our stories and we try to add a little
bit more detail for you to digest go and
check it out as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next
[Music]
time but